c'est une rare incursion dans une ville
complètement défiguré une ville en
ruines où la souffrance habite chaque
petit recoin
les habitants de mario paul déambule
dans les rues à leurs risques et périls
ils sont épuisés malade désorienté et
surtout à famille ça fait plus d'un mois
qu'ils sont privés de tous enfermés
comme des animaux en cas
on est sans électricité sans eau sans
gaz sans pain cris tamara de sa fenêtre
on vous a donné du macaroni dit elle
mais on doit le manger crus et des nous
c'est un cauchemar
mario paul est coupée du monde depuis
des semaines l'aide humanitaire
longtemps paralysé commence à peine à
arriver mais c'est le strict minimum il
faut faire la file pour une miche de
pain et pour de l'eau
mais pas
pour la ceni mode aller-retour
on a besoin de viande dit cette femme de
poisson pour rester en forme ne pas
perdre nos dents et nos cheveux le
pincer pour ne pas concret a ajouté
ni comme des zombies dans une ville
fantôme ces images et ces témoignages ne
sont qu'un aperçu du désespoir collectif
nous n'avons plus d'endroit où aller dit
natalia ivanova nous sommes chez nous
ont botté niépce un travail sans maison
sans rien il va vouloir de nous
beaucoup n'ont même plus où dormir il se
contente d'un petit bout de trottoir
pour fermer les yeux
le temps d'oublier leur cruel destin la
fatigue la faim la soif ne sont pas les
pires des supplices pour ceux qui
cherchent désespérément leurs proches
anatole nous sommes ici le texte sur la
fiche une date en dons à cette adresse
en espèrant qu'anatole soit encore en
vie
natalia aussi cherchent à fille elle est
introuvable ce but avait
plus de vingt mille civils auraient été
tués selon le maire de mario paul qui a
trouvé refuge à l'extérieur de la ville
l'armée russe contrôle maintenant plus
de 80% de la ville et tout son
patrimoine
[Applaudissements]
le désormais tristement célèbre théâtre
de mario paul n'est plus qu'une ruine
hanté par la mort
notre équipe guidée par l'armée russe
vient tout juste de découvrir les corps
calciné d'une femme et d'un enfant ils
étaient des civils innocents qui s'était
comme tant d'autres réfugiés ici pour
échapper aux bombardements
soldats russes ni encore toute
responsabilité le théâtre n'a pas été
bombardés dit-il l'explosion est
survenue à l'intérieur on a des preuves
et combien d'autres corps se cache sous
les décombres celui qui a été désigné
chef de la ville par l'armée russe
l'ignorent
il dit que deux équipes ont été déployés
sur le terrain pour les entreposer dans
des réfrigérateurs ou dans des morts
car pour l'instant ils sont dans nos
jardins cette
auto dont vous paraître chocolat qui est
à l'essai à treignes après déjà allés
il espère qu'un jour les victimes seront
enterrés avec dignité une fois les
combats terminés ce qui reste de
résistance ukrainienne à mario paul est
retranché dans cet immense complexe
industriel et les combats telle une
guérilla urbaine se font entendre au
centre-ville mais plus personne sur sow
c'est la trame sonore du calvaire
quotidienne de leurs apocalypse